hey everybody welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast my name is
Eric Trexler and I'm going to be your
one and only host for today's show uh
this will be yet another solo show at
this point the stronger by science
podcast co-host Union has walled me off
entirely uh as listeners know I've taken
a lot of major steps to accommodate
every single demand that they've put on
the table but now there is a deafening
silence and it is truly unsettling uh
given the fact that they are completely
putting the wall up not negotiating not
responding to messages I can only
imagine what they're up to and this is a
really really troubling scenario which
has disrupted my ability to sleep at
night so as a result this episode is
going to be all about the relationship
between sleep and fitness but before we
get into that a quick reminder that if
you like the show and you want to
support it during this completely
illegal strike there are many ways you
could do that so first of all you could
like rate or subscribe wherever you get
the podcast
you could also check out the email
newsletter that we send out every
Wednesday you can find more about that
and sign up at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter if you're looking for
one-on-one virtual coaching you can find
that as well at strongerbyscience.com
coaching if you are looking for a
discount on your supplements head over
to bulksupplements.com and use our
discount code the code is SBS pod and it
gets you five percent off your order of
course you could also support the show
by checking out the mass research review
or by checking out the macro Factor Diet
app which we the stronger by science
team co-developed with an extremely
talented team of colleagues if you want
to check it out before you commit there
is a free trial so you can take it for a
spin and see if you like it and I think
you might now
to start out here as we're talking about
sleep and Fitness
I want to begin by just talking very
briefly about sleep and the relationship
to just General Health and Wellness I
want to talk a little bit about
circadian biology and how sleep kind of
fits into the picture there so we're
going to work our way toward a more
directly Fitness related topics as we go
here but starting out I want to begin
with just a very superficial look at the
relationship between sleep patterns and
overall health and wellness and to look
at this I think it's very helpful to
begin by looking at research in shift
workers it's kind of a unique what we
would call a research model for looking
at sleep disturbances and circadian
rhythm disruptions and seeing how that
might impact Health in the real world so
when I talk about shift workers here I'm
talking about people who work in an
occupation where irregular work hours
are the norm so for example
nurses you know it'd be great if we
could all make a deal as a society that
no one has medical emergencies after 5
PM on weekdays uh and certainly none on
holidays but unfortunately we don't have
the ability to make that deal and so we
need people who can administer health
services and and provide Health Care
during irregular hours you know we can't
just shut down the hospital at 5 pm and
come back the next morning and hope for
the best uh same thing goes for
occupations like firefighters and you
know emergency medical personnel there
are many jobs where as as a society we
simply need people to be able to uh to
do these jobs and provide these services
for our communities at irregular hours
and so because of that there are going
to be people who need to work some
pretty unusual shifts you know people
who work overnight people who kind of go
back and forth between day shifts and
night shifts and even people who will
work for example an entire 24-hour shift
in a row which I believe is fairly
common for firefighters in the United
States so before we get into the actual
uh Health outcomes that we see in shift
workers in the research I want to start
by just briefly talking about
chronobiology now chronobiology is the
um the relationship between time and
biology or the relationship between I
guess you would say circadian rhythms
and biology so we know that
chronobiology is very important and we
know that there are many biological
processes that are dictated by
synchronized time-linked circadian
rhythms so some examples of biological
processes that occur with some degree of
circadian rhythmicity basically
fluctuating on a repeatable cycle
throughout the day uh hormone levels so
there are some hormones that have these
patterns where they elevate at certain
times of the day and they go down at
other certain times of the day and we
see that repeating in a regular sequence
so for a number of hormones a physician
might say hey when you get this retested
make sure you go in the morning you know
because we need to compare a morning
value to a morning value not a morning
value to a night value the Sleep wakes
cycle of course is going to be something
that is is very directly impacted with
some circadian rhythmicity uh you know
we don't just kind of have this random
assortment of times where we go to sleep
and wake up naturally we tend to fall
within a pattern then of course we're
going to talk about that more uh core
body temperature does tend to have some
fluctuation throughout the day in a
repeatable cycle and even immune system
activity as well so there are a number
of these different biological processes
that are intrinsically linked to
circadian rhythmicity and like I said
chronobiology basically is just in an
umbrella term that refers to uh
biological processes that are somewhat
time-linked and rep and are they display
some of these uh rhythmic patterns
um related to one's circadian rhythms so
the human body uh in order to actually
control some of these processes the
human body has Central and peripheral
circadian clocks and clocks is kind of a
metaphor but that's what they're called
when you talk about them um you know
I've taken lectures in various
physiology courses we do call them
circadian clocks and they essentially
coordinate circadian rhythms and of and
by extension the related biological
processes that are linked to circadian
rhythms
um and so these clocks uh the term that
we often use in the field is they are
entrained basically the clocks are
responding to stimuli that help them
understand approximately what
metaphorical time it is you know they
don't really care the number you know is
it 3 P.M or 4 P.M but but these
circadian clocks need to be essentially
tuned and calibrated based on key
stimuli
now there is a term for the stimuli and
we call them uh zeitgebers which is a
German term uh but that it roughly
translates to the term time givers so
there are all these different zeitgebers
that are helping our Central and
peripheral uh circadian clocks get an
idea of you know approximately when
things should be moving along based on
circadian rhythm so these clocks are
getting continuously entrained using uh
these different stimuli to coordinate
these responses that are supposed to be
changing within these uh pre-specified
patterns
um now when it comes to zeitgebers
without question light is the most
important zeitgeber it is the most
important stimulus that in trains and
calibrates and tunes are circadian
clocks and so what that means is if your
light dark cycle is miscalibur rated it
can really severely impact physiological
processes like sleep so getting back to
shift workers shift work often involves
irregular sleep patterns or sometimes an
uncoupling where this sleep wake cycle
is uncoupled from our natural light dark
cycle so what that means is when we talk
about irregular sleep patterns like I
said there are some folks who in their
occupation they oscillate back and forth
sometimes they work the day shift
sometimes they work the night shift and
they're kind of constantly bouncing back
and forth or they might do one for a few
weeks and the other for a few weeks but
I have heard of scenarios where even
within the same exact week you have
somebody doing two day shifts and a
night shift which of course is a very
very irregular sleep pattern and then I
also mentioned there's the possibility
that even if you don't have an irregular
pattern
there could be this uncoupling or
decoupling of the sleep wake cycle from
the light dark cycle so normally under
typical circumstances uh from an
evolutionary perspective human beings we
like to be awake during the day when
it's bright out and we like to sleep at
night when it's dark out if you always
work the night shift you have this
inversion where all of a sudden when
it's dark out that's when you're awake
when it's light out that's when you're
sleeping so what we often see is for
people who do shift work these
individuals often experience some degree
of circadian rhythm disruption or
circadian rhythm misalignment that can
cause sleep disruption because obviously
this uh you know because of this shift
in the light dark cycle uncoupling from
the sleep wake cycle one of the most
well probably the most important
zeitgeber is now leading to this kind of
miscalibration of of a number of
biological processes including
sleepiness and wakefulness so this
misalignment or disruption of circadian
rhythms can lead to sleep disruption and
when we look at the shift work research
there seems to be a very clear a very
clear line between this sleep disruption
and a number of cardio metabolic
perturbations and so as a result of
those fluctuations changes perturbations
what we see is that shift work is often
associated with a number of cardio
metabolic risk factors and chronic
disease States so in many cases we'll
see elevated risk for certain chronic
diseases and elevated risk of things
like overweight and obesity for example
now I want to be clear
this does not mean that shift workers
cannot be healthy this just means that
the shift work probably isn't doing them
any favors as they pursue Optimal Health
for themselves now people who do shift
work can probably overcome a great deal
of the risk elevation that's associated
with doing this shift work and the way
they would overcome that is by doing
their best to support their cardio
metabolic health so of course there's
the obvious stuff
um you know exercise nutrition we know
the drill another thing that they can do
is try to focus uh really give a lot of
focus to enhancing Sleep Quality to the
best of their ability I'm going to get
into the details uh later in this
episode about how you would actually do
that how you could strategically try to
enhance your Sleep Quality another thing
they can try to do is uh modify or
manipulate their light and dark exposure
now normally we don't have to do much
about this this you know if you are
awake during the day and you sleep at
night uh usually you don't have to go
too far out of your way to artificially
create a a really suitable light dark
cycle now if you're doing shift work you
might have to actually fabricate or or
kind of synthetically create a situation
where you have appropriate light
exposure at the right time and
appropriate lack of light exposure at
the right time and so what that would
look like
is making sure that your sleeping
environment is very very dark and one of
the things I like to do is I actually
wear an eye mask to sleep and I also
wear earplugs to sleep which is great
because once I get used to that I know
that wherever I'm sleeping even if I'm
traveling and I don't know you know what
the room is going to be like when I get
there I can always ensure that I'm going
to be sleeping in a quiet comfortable
dark environment because I bring the
quiet and the dark with me
um so so that's something that's been
very helpful to me but you want to make
sure you're sleeping in a dark
environment you want to make sure that
you're not exposing your eyeballs to a
bunch of really bright light in the
hours immediately preceding bed and so
usually what that means is a shift
worker they might be working in an
environment where there's a bunch of
really bright lights
um you know when they get home from that
shift they might want to really focus on
having at least an hour or two where
they're you know in dim lighting and
preferably avoiding bright light lights
and lights that are of a you know with
blue wavelengths uh the other thing that
I want to do is aside from avoiding uh
bright lights at night they also might
want to find a strategy to get some
bright light exposure in the morning
shortly after waking
now this is more possible than ever
because there are now a number of
products that try to essentially
replicate sunlight and so you can kind
of do a version of kind of at-home light
therapy where shortly upon waking you
try to expose yourself to some of these
Bright Lights of course you never want
to look directly into a super bright
light but but I know that there are a
number of products out there that try to
replicate the experience of sunlight
exposure and these have these have
become more popular and they come in
handy when you live somewhere with a
really high latitude in the winter time
days get very very very short
um you know I've had some some clients
who live in uh you know Sweden Finland
you know some of these areas in the uh
the Northern Hemisphere very high
latitude during the winter time it's
really hard to get sunlight exposure in
the morning because the sun just isn't
going to be up for a while so there are
number of products on the market now
where you can try to basically
artificially replicate a light dark
cycle that is more compatible with you
know your sleep wake cycle so you're
kind of trying to manipulate the the
this important zeitgeeber of light so
that you can alter your light dark cycle
to match your sleep wake cycle
um now I I will admit some of those
products I'm sure are very very
expensive these these different light
sources that try to replicate sunlight I
will admit and acknowledge I have not
priced them out I don't know what the
going rate is I would imagine there's a
pretty big spread in terms of pricing uh
I haven't looked into it so if these are
just impossibly expensive and therefore
this advice isn't very good I apologize
in advance but it is an option that I
know exists so what should you do if you
work in an occupation where shift work
is common this is something that I have
navigated previously uh there are many
people close to me in my life people who
are very important to me who do shift
work and and sometimes I'll when they're
changing jobs or applying to jobs I
might you know drop a little bit of you
know I might give them my two cents
about what would be a suitable way to go
so I think if you can swing it day shift
would be idea deal but of course that's
not always going to be an option you
know people really like to work the day
shift so that that can be hard to come
by uh if you can't work the day shift I
actually personally would prefer to work
night shift only so rather than going
back and forth I'd say okay if I can't
do all day shift I'd rather do all night
shift and that way I can do some of
these strategies to try to sync up my my
light dark cycle with my sleep wake
cycle
to me the worst of Both Worlds would be
oscillating back and forth between day
shifts and night shifts to me that would
not be in a night and not be an ideal
scenario and if possible I would try to
avoid it but of course I understand it's
not always possible we got to do what we
got to do to make a living sometimes
it's going to be unavoidable but no
matter the scenario you know you want to
just be mindful of those behaviors so
that you can modify those behaviors and
ultimately try to reduce
any chronic disease risk or cardio
metabolic outcomes that have been
associated with shift work in the past
and like I said there are modifiable
things we can do to attenuate some of
those risk factor elevations so we want
to focus strategically on light dark
exposure we want to focus on Sleep
Quality and we want to focus on just
good old exercise and nutrition so now I
want to talk I want to kind of shift the
conversation and talk more about sleep
as it pertains to more Fitness oriented
good outcomes one of the things that a
lot of people have noticed if you're
listening you've probably noticed this
as well if you've been in the exercise
game for a while
when we are getting poor sleep either
we're getting insufficient amounts of
sleep or insufficient Sleep Quality a
lot of times we will find that training
quality goes down significantly so it's
very very common to see a major
impairment of training quality when you
are either not sleeping enough or not
sleeping well enough so I'm going to
link a couple papers one is by kirchen
and colleagues the other by Craven and
colleagues they talk a little bit about
uh how are training quality specifically
is likely to be impaired or impeded by
insufficient sleep the specific
impairments that we tend to see in this
literature overall we see impairments in
endurance capacity work capacity we see
an increased level of perceived exertion
per unit of work so what that means is
you do the same workout but it just
feels way way harder or you try to do
the same workout but it feels so much
harder that you're unable to do it
effectively uh execution of Highly
skilled tasks so what I mean there is if
you are really really under slept uh is
it going to impair your ability to do a
leg extension or a bicep curl maybe if
if it's you know exertion is really high
you're trying to do a bunch of work
capacity or you know more of a muscular
endurance task you could see some of
those big impacts on a very simple
Movement Like A bicep curl or a leg
extension but when we talk about a
snatch a clean and jerk a squat a
deadlift as we get into some of these
more skilled movements we start to see
even bigger impairments in terms of
performance uh in the gym and our
overall training quality so it's it's
not that the unskilled movements or the
lower skilled movements are unimpacted
at all you know it's not like there's
absolutely no impact but the impact is
much bigger when we're looking at some
of these more um skill-dependent
movements and then finally another
specific impairment that we see in the
literature is just recovery it it seems
when we're chronically under slept it
seems to be a little bit more difficult
to recover from our training uh from our
training uh sessions our workouts so
just to reiterate here you know if you
are doing
a program that involves uh a ton of
really uh low repetition sets with very
very low skill movements and the overall
volume of your program is low so if for
some reason you know you're going in and
you're doing a lot of triples on the leg
extension and you're not accumulating a
lot of volume that workout might not get
impacted all that much by Sleep
restriction of course if you get into
very very extreme sleep restriction then
you're going to start to see bigger
changes
um you know but but when we talk about
most common training programs with the
type of work capacity that they demand
the type of movements that they demand
most folks listening to this are going
to notice a pretty meaningful drop in
training quality if they're getting
insufficient sleep most practically
applicable training programs are going
to be hit
relatively hard by by severe sleep
impairment the degree to which your
program or your training your training
quality is impacted is going to come
down to the specific elements of the
training program like I said endurance
work capacity perceived exertion
skillful execution and Recovery another
area for Fitness enthusiasts where where
we see some pretty major downsides from
insufficient sleep
is when we look at appetite now we did a
episode recently that was all about
hunger and appetite management one thing
that I didn't get into because I knew I
was going to save it for this episode is
that insufficient sleep can have a
pretty big impact on appetite and hunger
and specifically it can lead us in a
direction that predisposes over
consumption so it usually pushes Us in
the direction of overeating because of
an elevation and appetite and there's a
paper I'm going to link it in the show
notes it's called Sleep debt and obesity
by Bayon and colleagues and they had a
couple really nice they had some nice
tables and figures in their paper one
figure in particular figure one it's a
really nice overview I love a good
figure by the way when I'm going through
scientific papers figures are truly
terrific
um great way to convey a lot of
information very simply but figure one
of this paper talks about how sleep debt
so basically this chronic accumulation
of many nights of poor sleep over time
how sleep debt can ultimately predispose
weight gain and the development of
obesity looking at the behavioral side
there might be reductions in total daily
energy expenditure less physical
activity more time to eat because we're
just awake more but that we also see
specifically when it comes to appetite
increases in snacking increases in
alcohol consumption and just a general
tendency toward poor diet quality we see
that people tend to eat more they tend
to have cravings for for foods that we
would generally categorize as a pretty
low quality diet we tend to see that
people are snacking more and ultimately
that they are consuming a lot more
energy than they had intended now figure
one in that paper also looks at a bunch
of other biological pathways that are
impacted by uh by Sleep debt a bunch of
you know biological Pathways that can
ultimately uh predispose weight gain and
obesity as well I'm going to save those
for another day but ultimately in a
nutshell what we're talking about there
with those biological Pathways it's a
whole bunch of stuff that generally
increases hunger and increases appetite
and another thing I will mention that's
not in this figure is the fact that
there's an interesting kind of Triad a
bit of a three-way relationship uh
between poor sleep in terms of quality
and quantity uh stress psychogenic
stress and food intake and a lot of
times what we'll see is is that uh when
for example I'm going to treat uh sleep
as the causative Factor here but but
there is kind of a bi-directional thing
going on but when people are under slept
and you know they're sleeping poorly
they're not sleeping enough they're
accumulating a sleep debt a lot of times
we'll see that they become a little bit
more susceptible to stress just
day-to-day psychogenic stress and
sometimes that stress itself can also
lead to overeating because stress eating
is a thing a lot of times when we're
stressed out we do tend to overeat we
tend to have a poorer appetite
regulation and a lot of times we do have
increased craving for foods that like I
said probably aren't aren't the highest
quality foods in terms of their
nutritional value so there's this kind
of three-way relationship between sleep
debt stress and food consumption that
ultimately nudges Us in the direction of
over consumption uh number four or is
this number four number three I can't
tell but another thing to consider when
we're talking about
um you know Fitness related issues that
arise from insufficient sleep is just
less favorable changes in body
composition you know broadly speaking
I'm going to link a couple studies in
the show notes Here There are studies
where you know we see people doing these
interventions that are supposed to be
enhancing body composition
generally speaking the goal in these
studies is to gain or at least maintain
as much fat free mass as you can while
simultaneously losing as much fat mass
as you can a lot of times we see
unfavorable differences in both
directions so people will experience
less favorable changes in fat-free mass
and less or smaller reductions in fat
Mass when we compare a group who's
getting plenty of sleep to a group who
has impaired sleep so broadly speaking
we will see in some of these studies
that are looking at the impact of sleep
quantity and quality on body composition
we'll see less favorable changes on both
sides of the coin both when it comes to
muscle mass or fat free mass and the
ability to lose fat Mass so that's not
ideal and ultimately that's going to be
related to a lot of the stuff that we've
already covered so we talked about
impaired training quality of course
that's not going to be great for for
inducing really favorable changes in
body composition you know training is I
would say the most important lever that
we can pull in terms of uh
I don't want to get into that whole
thing about what percentage is training
what percentage is Diet but training is
important if you want to increase if you
want to improve body composition
especially if you want to build muscle
training is the most important level
that we can pull there so if you have
impaired uh training quality that's not
going to be great for improving body
composition if you have impaired
recovery then that is going to tie into
impaired training quality over time
again not going to be great and as we've
already covered
there seems to be a great deal of
appetite dysregulation and also just
dysregulation of more broadly speaking
desire to eat there seems to be more
food craving more tendency to opt for
Less Health compatible food options so
we see a number of reasons that an
individual would have greater challenges
building muscle and greater challenges
losing fat if they're chronically under
slept there are also some very direct
mechanisms by which lack of sleep could
impair hypertrophy that's an area where
I wish we had more research on the
relationship between sleep and
hypertrophy there is some very applied
research saying that you know what if
you're not sleeping enough makes it
pretty tough to lose a lot of weight
lose a lot of fat Mass
there's not as much research where we
have two groups of folks doing a
longitudinal training intervention we're
looking at hypertrophy one group uh you
know is on a restricted sleep protocol
and the others doing plenty of sleep
there is getting plenty of sleep
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
that research and it's understandable
why we don't have that research it's
very very difficult to get someone to
sign up for a study
and say guess what you're going to sleep
like crap for the next 12 weeks because
that's how long it's going to take to
get a really good look at hypertrophy
here with resistance training you know
it's it's not easy but it's easy enough
to get people in the lab and say hey
you're going to have one or two or three
crappy nights of sleep we'll make sure
it's not happening during midterms or
finals you'll be all right but when it
comes to multiple week protocols that's
a very very challenging thing to do it's
a big burden to put on a research
participant and as someone who has been
in the trenches doing a whole bunch of
human subjects research you know you
really have to think about the burden
you're placing on participants when
you're designing any kind of
intervention type trial uh you know it's
absolutely critical for that trial to be
worth doing you have to make sure that
it's going to be feasible for
participants to do it and to not
perceive it as an insurmountable or just
completely you know just a completely
excessive burden that's going to make
their life a living hell for the next
two or three months so I understand why
we don't have a lot of that research but
there is some some more mechanistic
research that gives us Clues to indicate
that impairments in sleep probably will
uh lead to to some extent to impairments
in hypertrophy so we there I'm going to
link a couple studies in the show notes
here but there is some research
indicating that when we're under slept
we have a skewed balance of anabolic and
catabolic hormones that generally nudges
Us in in the direction of increased
catabolic hormones and and reduced
anabolic hormones now I don't like to
overstate the importance of some of
these short-term hormonal fluctuations
when it comes to hypertrophy and body
composition but
I think uh if you are having poor enough
sleep for a long enough time and really
accumulating a serious sleep debt uh I I
think it's very plausible to suggest
that these hormonal factors could become
relevant over time uh and then there's
also some research pointing to impaired
muscle protein synthesis uh when an
individual is under slept and has very
very poor Sleep Quality or quantity now
muscle protein synthesis is not
necessarily the exact same thing as
hypertrophy that's something we've
talked about on the podcast before it's
something that I've talked about I've
written about in the mass research
review a few times the two outcomes are
not perfectly correlated but in a
short-term study muscle protein
synthesis is often the best we can do
when we're trying to make inferences
about uh what would happen if we were
able to do this for 12 weeks and
actually study hypertrophy so those are
some of the issues we can run into to
both in terms of General Health and
Wellness but also related to more
Fitness related outcomes and so at this
point I want to shift the conversation
and talk a little bit more about
strategies to minimize the impact of
poor sleep so if you're someone who's
been sleeping very poorly uh what do we
do about that so that we can write the
ship and get to a spot where we are
effectively supporting Health wellness
and fitness related goals I'm going to
talk about strategies that kind of fit
on three different tiers in my opinion
we've got the least favorable strategies
the slightly more favorable strategies
and then the most favorable strategies
um so least favorable is going to be
caffeine napping and caffeinated napping
slightly more favorable would be just
kind of acutely when you're under slept
making some small modifications to your
training program so that you're not
going to have quite as notable an
impairment of training quality but the
most favorable in my opinion is to focus
on sleep hygiene principles in order to
improve your sleep quantity and quality
so the most favorable thing is to
directly fix the problem but we are
going to talk about all three of these
categories so starting out uh caffeine
like I said not what I would call a
super favorable
strategy here but it does work right so
there's no surprises here if you consume
caffeine when you're under slept it will
offset some of the sleepiness that
you're experiencing it will increase
wakefulness and there's a a position
stand or a position statement by the
Journal of the international Society of
Sports Nutrition the lead author was Dr
guest so guests and colleagues wrote
this paper I was very very fortunate to
be able to contribute to that paper and
there's a quote from that paper just to
kind of give you uh get right to the
conclusion here caffeine May improve
cognitive and physical performance in
some individuals under conditions of
sleep deprivation so caffeine there's
quite a few studies indicating that it
offsets some elements of sleep
deprivation or impaired Sleep Quality or
quantity however
this is a short-term solution kind of a
Band-Aid solution you're not actually
fixing the problem you're trying to just
kind of circumvent it with a short-term
strategy because here's the problem if
you rely too heavily on caffeine a lot
of times you will pay a price afterward
uh that that might be an exaggeration a
bit too serious of languages that you're
going to pay the price but there are
some downsides and uh you know the the
downsides ultimately in my opinion uh in
some cases can outweigh the upside so
yes you get this this short-term
solution that allows you to offset uh
some of the downsides of sleep
deprivation but
caffeine has a pretty long Half-Life uh
you know for a lot of folks it's going
to be five to eight hours
um I I co-authored a textbook chapter a
while back about caffeine one of the
things that I find amazing about
caffeine is if you look into the
literature for Half-Life estimates the
original papers documenting uh Half-Life
estimates of caffeine the variability is
immense I mean I I've seen I believe I'm
going off memory here I believe I've
seen some estimates where the half-life
in a particular paper they estimate it's
about two or three hours I've seen
others where it's up in the 10 to 12
hour range and so the half-life we're
talking about just eliminating half of
the concentration from the blood and we
talk about the time it takes to do that
but but the reason we care about a
half-life
we use this as a metric for how long is
this going to be in my system uh doing
its thing and so the problem with a long
Half-Life like I said it's usually
people will say five to six hours five
to eight hours it depends a lot it
varies from person to person but that's
about the time frame we're talking about
when we have a half-life that long it
means if you have caffeine late in the
day uh it's still going to be in your
system when it's time to lay down and go
to sleep and it could actually impair
your ability to fall asleep or the
quality of sleep that you get that night
and so what we see is this uh fairly
vicious cycle where you have been
getting crappy sleep so you lean on
caffeine but then the caffeine because
you're leaning on it so much
particularly late in the day it's
causing you to have crappy sleep and so
then the crappy sleep leads to the
caffeine the caffeine leads to the
crappy sleep and we're really not
getting anywhere you know we just have a
lot of short-term Solutions and we're
paying paying the price on the back end
so when I say late in the day a lot of
times people will ask you know okay so
how long do I have to wait or how long
of a of a gap do I need between my last
caffeine dose and the time I go to bed
ultimately I don't think I have a good
answer to that and it's not it's not for
lack of trying like I said when I was
writing that textbook chapter several
years back I was digging into the
literature pretty hard and I can tell
you based on a study that I'm going to
link in the show notes
um it's probably at least six hours for
most people uh the clearance time the
half-life of caffeine is going to vary
from person to person uh I would expect
that the dose that you're getting uh for
your last caffeine dose before bed
probably matters so you can probably
have a small caffeine dose closer to bed
rather than a really large caffeine dose
within the same time frame I don't know
if I can give a great answer but I can
say based on the evidence it's probably
at least six hours but what I would
encourage people to do is uh try to help
yourself out you know so if you think it
might be six hours see if you can do
eight see if you could do ten see if you
can even do 12. what I encourage people
to do is pay attention to when you know
the days where you wake up feeling like
you got really poor sleep versus the
days where you wake up feeling really
really refreshed and really uh you know
you feel like you just got really great
sleep pay attention to your caffeine
timing for some folks you might be able
to get away with having caffeine four
hours before bed others it might be six
others it might be eight or ten or
twelve and I would encourage people to
experiment with that because that's a
pretty important variable that is pretty
easy to manipulate and strategically
adjust so I would encourage people to
guess and check and if you're not sure I
mean ultimately it's a matter of
priority but I air on a longer gap
between my caffeine intake and the time
I go to bed lately in the past several
years
I've really been trying to push a lot
more of my caffeine intake earlier in
the day and I've actually been reducing
my caffeine intake quite a lot I used to
to drink a really absurd amount of
caffeine on a daily basis I've cut that
down I've shifted it earlier in the day
I try to keep it all in the morning
before uh before noon uh and that's been
pretty helpful for me so might be a
little bit of guessing check that you
have to do but ultimately you want to
make sure that you're not uh having a
bunch of caffeine right before bed uh
one thing I will note the last thing
I'll mention on this topic is some
people make what I consider to be an
erroneous conclusion
and they'll say well I had caffeine two
hours before bed and I fell asleep just
fine
falling asleep is not the same thing as
having a really great high quality night
of sleep there are some folks who will
fall asleep well and say well clearly
the caffeine didn't have an effect but
if you sleep like crap or you're tossing
and turning or you just wake up and you
don't feel like you're very rested and
refreshed it's possible that you've
impacted Sleep Quality without impacting
sleep quantity another thing you know
just in analogous situation sometimes
people will have alcohol before bed
which can disrupt Sleep Quality and some
people have alcohol before bed and say
oh I slept great no big deal it didn't
have an impact well the effect of
alcohol in the nighttime hours the
effect that it has on sleep is pretty
complicated well it's not that
complicated it's it's not rocket science
but it's a little bit more nuanced than
just good or bad because you know
alcohol acutely has a bit of a sedative
effect where you know we drink a little
bit of alcohol you know sometimes people
say I like to have a glass of wine it
helps me get to sleep at night or
something like that so there is acutely
in effect where we get a little bit
sleepy sometimes it helps us doze off a
little bit but what we often find in the
literature
is when people have too much alcohol
before bed they get to sleep just fine
but a few hours into that night of sleep
sleep quality really starts to take a
hit they might be tossing and turning
they might be waking up several times
throughout the night usually it's the
Sleep Quality specifically during the
second half of that night of sleep that
seems to be impacted more moving on to
napping once again no surprises here I
think people intuitively have known
since they were essentially a baby if
I'm sleepy and grumpy a little nap can
help and I feel a little bit more
refreshed after that nap there was a
paper by hasuna and colleagues that my
dear friend Dr Eric Helms reviewed in
the mass research review
their finding just to put it in a
nutshell from this study they were
looking at the effects of napping on a
number of performance related outcomes
and they found that a nap opportunity
has a beneficial effect on physical
performance and attention with better
results observed for naps greater than
or equal to 35 minutes in duration so
much like caffeine
taking a little nap you know 30 45
minutes give or take uh maybe even an
hour is likely to offset some elements
of sleep deprivation but just like
caffeine this is what I would call kind
of a short-term Band-Aid solution the
reason I say that if we lean too heavily
on naps once again we can pay a bit of a
price afterward it kind of catches up to
us on the back end if we nap for too
long or we nap too late in the day that
can make it hard to get high quality
sleep the subsequent night so now
napping has caused a bit of sleep
disruption and here we are again in that
vicious cycle where the nap causes sleep
disruption the Sleep disruption makes it
such that we need a nap which causes
sleep disruption and there we go again
back and forth now what about both why
choose one when you can do both we we've
got the idea of caffeinated napping and
there was a study fairly recently by
ramdani and colleagues which I'll link
in the show notes I actually did a
research Spotlight about that uh for
Stronger by science so if you are a
member of the email newsletter if you
get that every Wednesday this study
might ring a bell and I believe I
covered this in the mass research review
as well uh so what they were looking at
here was the idea of a caffeinated nap
and what that means is you're consuming
caffeine right before the onset of a nap
and you might be thinking well how is
that even going to work right if you're
having caffeine it's going to make it
hard to take a nap well the reason this
is a viable strategy is because when we
consume caffeine I mean it's going to
start getting into your bloodstream
quickly if if we're talking about just
detecting any at all but usually it's
going to take a good 30 to 45 minutes
for caffeine to have its peak effect in
terms of maximizing levels in
circulation and maximize or you know
beginning to enhance uh you know
wakefulness alertness
Etc so it usually takes 30 or 45 minutes
for that caffeine to really kick in
uh which is pretty convenient because
that means if you have this caffeine
right before you begin the nap the
caffeine is really going to start to hit
as your nap is winding down so you can
lay down for a nice 30 45 minute nap
maybe an hour when you wake up that
caffeine is starting to to kind of
really kick in and that puts you in a
spot where you can kind of Leverage both
of these strategies
simultaneously uh and there is some
research supporting um the effectiveness
of this particular approach for exercise
applications so so it is a viable
strategy but uh you know if we talk
about combining two kind of short-term
Band-Aid strategies uh we just have two
different Band-Aids here so it still
would fall under the umbrella of what I
would call some of the least favorable
approaches doesn't mean it doesn't work
but it really is a short-term strategy
that's not addressing the actual problem
so if it's going to be a one-time thing
sure caffeine nap caffeinated nap nobody
big deal you know it's going to help you
get through that training session but if
we're talking about a daily thing might
not be ideal
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than predicting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul writer
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
now a slightly more favorable strategy
than you know napping or caffeine like I
mentioned is to make some strategic
modifications to your training program
so we can do this strategically because
like I mentioned previously if we look
at the literature on how sleep
deprivation impacts exercise
or training quality we can look at these
specific elements of training quality
that seem to be most negatively impacted
and so what we're trying to do here if
we're going to modify our training
program is we want to make our training
program different so that it relies Less
on the elements of training that are
most severely impacted by impaired sleep
so what we want to do you know if you're
focusing on strength if strength is your
main outcome that you're that you're
training for you might want to opt for
simpler movements you know so maybe a
leg press instead of a squat and you
want to aim for low volume with low rep
ranges and so what that'll do if you're
a strength focused lifter and you're
focusing on simple movements with low
volume and low repetition ranges that
should attenuate some of those negative
impacts that sleep impairment has on
endurance work capacity and the execute
solution of skillful movements or
physical tasks so that would be how I
adjust the program if I'm training for
strength now if I'm training mostly for
hypertrophy
what I want to do there is opt for
strategies that allow me to accumulate
plenty of volume in my training session
with a reduced perception of effort
because like I said if you're in a very
volume heavy hypertrophy focused
training block you might notice that
sleep deprivation because it increases
perceived exertion during a training
bout you might find that it's really
hard to complete your normal amount of
training volume without making some
modifications so one of the things I
like to do and Dr Mike zordos wrote
about this recently in the mass research
review one of the strategies I like to
do I didn't actually know there was a
name for it this is just something I had
done uh pretty frequently and that then
he reviewed this study I said oh cool
there's a name but the name is rest
redistribution sets and to give an
example let's say I was going to do a
normal uh you know a normal approach to
training and I'm going to do three sets
of six repetition editions with maybe
three minutes of rest in between those
sets three sets of six plenty of rest
between those sets pretty normal setup
there instead of that
what you would do
with a rest redistribution strategy is
you would do nine sets of two with only
45 seconds of rest between those sets
now I don't follow that type of protocol
religiously but the general idea is that
instead of having these really discreet
sets that are kind of blocked off where
we do a really uh challenging bout here
or really good effort and then pause for
an extended period of time two or three
minutes and then we do another discrete
set of effort what we're doing is just
kind of spreading this effort out we do
a couple reps wait a little bit do a
couple more wait a little bit do a
couple more and so the reason that I
kind of eased my way into this strategy
without knowing it existed is because
back in the day I did a little bit of
blood flow restricted training when I
was injured and the most common protocol
that you see in the literature for blood
flow restricted training is 30 15 50 15.
so basically what you do
and like I said I prefer to use this
when I'm um like injured or training
around something but you let's say
you're doing leg extensions you'd you
know get get all wrapped up For Your
Blood Flow Restriction you do a set of
30 and take a relatively brief pause
between between sets and then do 15 a
brief pause 15 brief pause 15. and the
the brief pause in there you get the
idea that this is kind of just one big
prolonged set in a way and you're just
kind of spreading it out you start out
with a pretty tough uh you know set of
30 and then you're just kind of doing
you know almost like back off sets but
it's all one big kind of prolonged set
because you're keeping the wrap tight uh
and you're not taking long rest periods
so basically I had
um
without thinking too much about it I
don't like to go into like the you know
the the bodybuilding websites and say I
need a name for whatever I'm doing I
like to focus more on training
principles I feel like if you've studied
exercise at the University level for 10
years you should be able to figure it
out without without somebody telling you
you're allowed to do this because it has
a name so I I really try to focus on the
principles
um that I've learned of just learning
physiology for a long time and so for me
what I found was when I would walk into
the gym and just feel like crap you know
maybe I'm under slept maybe I'm really
mentally fatigued
um you know in my line of work mental
fatigue sneaks up on me you start riding
you get caught up in it you want to go
to the gym and you're just like man my
brain is fried so if I'm really mentally
fatigued or I'm really under slept uh
you know if I've got a lot of sleep debt
that has built up I might get on a chest
press machine you know low skill
movement and I'm just trying to focus on
hypertrophy actually I really like the
the free motion cable chest machine
where I do a lot of chest flies I've
been loving that one lately
um I might get on there put in a really
manageable load
um you know with the little uh
selectorizer thing there so put the pin
in there nice easy load maybe do a set
of 10 or 15.
take a little bit of a of a break not
very long and then just do a number of
smaller sets so usually you know I'm not
trying to push that first set you know
really really close to failure just want
to feel a good effort you know leave a
handful of reps in reserve but you know
I might start out with a higher rep
effort and then I just kind of back off
and take a little break do a set of six
or seven take a little break do a set of
five or six take a little break do a set
of you know four or five you know so
over the course of it I'm not fully
recovering between these little breaks
um I'm just kind of doing this giant set
and I'm accumulating this volume and I
notice that because I'm not you know
taking a long rest for full recovery my
repetition range starts to kind of Trail
off as I do each of these little
clusters of repetition so that is you
know if I was doing a hypertrophy focus
training program and I was really
focused on attenuating uh the the impact
of the Sleep debt I had been building up
that's a strategy that I've personally
been really fond of and only recently
did I find out oh there's kind of a name
for that which is nice now that's an
okay strategy but
you know you're not going to pay for it
on the back end it's not like you're
going to say well I did this rest
redistribution approach and therefore
I'm going to sleep like crap again
tonight you know you don't have that
same immediate payment that you owe for
using this strategy that's why I prefer
it uh over mapping or caffeine is
because we can just say hey I feel like
crap today let's change up the training
program a little bit just for today get
a great night night of sleep and get
back on our regularly scheduled
programming
um you know I wouldn't want to change it
every day because ultimately
if you have to modify your training
program every single day because you
feel like crap you're not really on that
training program anymore you know you're
not able to adhere to it because of the
Sleep impairment so this strategy is
okay but obviously it's not something we
want to do every single day because then
your training program is no longer your
training program but the best case
scenario uh you know the the absolute uh
most favorable approach to uh to Trying
to minimize the impact of poor sleep is
to actually fix the problem and what we
want to do is focus on sleep hygiene
principles to maximize the likelihood
that we're going to get in a you know
high enough sleep quality and high
enough sleep quantity so I mentioned way
back earlier in this episode uh I said
you know hey if you're doing shift work
you might want to try to just really
focus in on Sleep Quality and I said
yeah I'll get to that later this is what
I'm talking about is using the
principles of good sleep hygiene to try
to maximize your ability to get really
high quality sleep and to get enough
sleep every night now there are a lot of
different recommendations pertaining to
sleep hygiene you can find a lot of
different lists a lot of different sleep
foundations have their own kind of
preferred set a lot of different health
related organizations now have you know
their set of recommendations one that
I'm going to use here is the Norwegian
competence Center for Sleep Disorders
um
and the reason I'm using this is because
I wrote about a study uh in the mass
research review a couple years back that
actually was studying what happens when
you try to do this as an intervention so
it's a nice little set of criteria that
is drawn from a very Fitness related
paper where the outcomes were quite
positive so uh in terms of sleep hygiene
tips number one in this list is keep it
dark quiet and cool in the room where
you sleep number two go to bed and wake
up at the same time during the whole
week including the weekends having a
regular sleep wake cycle is really
really helpful number three go to bed so
that you can actually get about eight
hours of sleep oh so the first step in
getting eight hours of sleep is giving
yourself an eight hour opportunity to
sleep uh number four
they're talking about tips to implement
two hours before bedtime first of all
turn down the lights dim light avoiding
really bright light and blue wavelength
light the second one put away uh screens
so your computer iPad mobile phones
um it put those things away or dim them
and try to use a blue light filter third
one no exercise the reason they say that
if you do a bunch of really intense
exercise very shortly before bed it
could potentially interfere with Sleep
Quality but doing a lot of exercise
earlier in the day actually helps with
Sleep Quality so with exercise the
timing and the intensity seem to be
important you don't want to do a bunch
of really intense exercise immediately
before bed uh the next one
no food coffee or black tea or
caffeinated drinks so you don't want to
have a really big meal right before bed
and you certainly don't want to be
consuming uh caffeinated beverages the
next one here within these two hours
before bed uh do some calm and positive
activities and don't bring up relational
conflicts before bedtime so the whole
idea there is you want to get your mind
into a state where being calm and
restful is possible you don't want to do
things that are really stressful really
cognitively demanding really emotionally
upsetting you want to put yourself in a
mindset where you're really able to
start calming down and easing into a
state of really high quality relaxation
uh five when you get up in the morning
expose yourself to as much light as
possible right away number six last cup
of coffee should be six hours before
bedtime like I said I would frame that
as being at least six hours before
bedtime for most individuals number
seven here try to get so much sleep that
you don't need an alarm clock to wake up
I know for some people that's going to
sound totally implausible and there have
been times in my life where where I
thought that sounded implausible but it
is actually a doable thing you'd be
really surprised if you are really
intentional about having a regular sleep
schedule and you know adhering to some
of these hygiene practices you might
find that you are regularly routinely
waking up without the use of an alarm
clock if you have an important meeting
you might want to set one anyway but but
you definitely can get there in many
many cases the next one do not use
electronic devices that emit light in
bed
um and I would say you know one of the
things you commonly see in these lists
is
the bed is you know you it's reserved
for a very select number of activities
uh with one of them being sleep so you
don't want to be sitting in bed doing
work throughout the day you don't want
to be doing uh in my opinion personally
a lot of effortful reading in bed you
know when you get into bed I like to
view that as it's time to sleep
um so number nine here the last one on
the list is learn a relaxation technique
uh and use it to fall asleep at night or
if you wake up during the night you know
do that relaxation technique again uh
you already know my bias here if you
listen to the podcast uh there are a lot
of meditation and mindfulness exercises
that are very very helpful for falling
falling asleep
um actually when I was a college student
in an undergrad student I took a yoga
course as part of my curriculum and at
the end of the yoga session the
instructor would often have us lay down
and just kind of walk us through a
really calming mindfulness kind of a
guided meditation almost and you know I
was I was in college I was having a lot
of fun studying just really busy
sleeping like crap doing doing what
college kids do and almost every single
time I fell asleep during the guided
mindfulness exercise and I will say I
mean there are some really incredible
now back in the day apps were kind of
few and far between but there are a lot
of really great apps and websites that
have guided meditations and guided
mindfulness exercises that are
specifically for relaxing calming your
mind and easing into sleep uh and they
tend to be very very effective in my
experience
now a couple other common ones that are
not on this Norwegian list that I that I
think are worth mentioning as I said
earlier uh don't drink too much alcohol
before bed uh that can definitely be
disruptive uh you might fall asleep very
well uh but in the later portion of the
night you might find that your sleep
quality is very disturbed and very
disrupted uh the other one is be mindful
of the meal that you're consuming before
bed so this list mentioned you know try
not to have a meal within two hours of
bedtime
I'm not necessarily as concerned about
the timing I'm more interested in the
composition of the meal my personal
experience and some of the research I've
looked at I'm not convinced that you
shouldn't consume anything within two
hours of bed there have been studies
with um with pre-bed protein intake that
seemed totally fine in terms of not
inducing major impairments in Sleep
Quality or quantity but like I said I'm
more interested not in the timing of
that meal but the actual composition so
you don't want that meal to be too large
you don't want it to be too fatty and
the reason we talk about those two is
just because of digestion
if you're consuming that meal in close
proximity to bed and it's a really heavy
meal it's really large there's a lot of
calorie content it's really fatty and
and fat does tend to digest pretty
slowly you might just find a situation
where your stomach is just really
unsettled as you're trying to sleep the
other thing I'll mention is research has
indicated that you don't want to go to
bed immediately after having a very
spicy meal so you don't want the meal to
be too large too fatty or too spicy when
it comes to these sleep hygiene tips the
most notable things from my perspective
in my personal experience and from
looking at the literature and by the way
I do want to mention I think it's
relevant here my personal experience
with sleep hygiene is extensive
I've talked about this before on many a
podcast I don't know if I've talked
about it on this one but uh back in I
think 27 19 that was when I uh earned my
Pro card a natural bodybuilding and made
my Pro debut in natural bodybuilding and
in order to do that I got very very lean
um you know I was one of those
bodybuilders who was never ever ever
going to be the most muscular on stage I
won by being very very lean and what
happens a lot of times with bodybuilders
who are prepping
is as they get really really lean as
they get closer to show time they they
often experience some pretty
considerable sleep disturbance and
people had asked me you know pretty
shortly after that competitive season
they said oh man that must have been
terrible I bet you were so lethargic you
were so hungry and I was like yeah I
mean yeah for sure but without question
by a mile the worst part of that prep
for me was not hunger was not food
cravings was not being lethargic
although I was very lethargic the
biggest issue for me was the massive
drop in Sleep Quality and sleep quantity
it was very very difficult for me to be
able to get to sleep
um and that is that is what happens
sometimes when you have very low energy
availability and very very low body fat
so I had to experiment with everything
in the book in terms of trying to give
myself an opportunity to sleep well
within those circumstances and what I
found based on the literature and my
personal experience is when we talk
about the most notable elements of sleep
hygiene the highest impact things you
can do I think first of all uh you know
being mindful of light and dark Cycles
is huge and second of all
being really consistent with your sleep
cycle so for me the most notable things
that I did that were very very helpful
and of course there are many things that
go into sleep hygiene but the big impact
stuff was light exposure early in the
morning along with a little bit of
physical activity going out for a walk
in the morning when the sun's Rising
avoiding light particularly blue light
in the evening
and really being very intentional about
going to bed at the same time every day
and trying to wake up at the same time
every day and going to bed is easy
that's an act where you just get in the
bed and you lay there so I could do that
every night waking up that was a
different story there was a time there
this this was this occurred during when
I was working on my PhD
and I know a lot of folks in the
department were like man this this Arab
Trexler he is a go-getter uh I was
getting to the lab sometimes at two in
the morning three in the morning four in
the morning would actually be kind of a
late start for me when I was in the
middle of this contest prep because I
would lay down and try to get to bed at
like eight or nine at night uh and I
mean I I just couldn't sleep for more
than I mean sometimes it would only be
three or four hours and I'd wake up and
just be wide awake and I'd say what what
the hell am I gonna do you know so I
might go to bed at at nine PM uh wake up
at midnight or 1am and just be staring
at the ceiling in my bedroom and say
well I am running a study here I might
as well go to the lab and get everything
ready to go for our subjects who are
coming in at six in the morning so uh
man thinking back at it that was a tough
time that was not a lot of fun but
anyway those were the things that were
most impact full and most helpful as I
was wrestling with these major
challenges
um it was really funny because you know
a natural bodybuilder when they're when
they're getting really really shredded
before a show
um you know people will say Hey you
really don't look very good right now
you know your face starts to look really
gaunt
um but I was so under slept people would
say Eric you look like absolute garbage
and I'd say what exactly are you
referring to are you referring to the
fact that I look like a person who
doesn't sleep anymore or the fact that
I'm wasting away it was really hard to
tell what they were really keying in on
when they noticed how terrible I looked
but that's all in the past and we're
good to go now
um now when I talk about light dark
Cycles circadian rhythm circadian
biology I know that a lot of people in
the evidence-based Fitness Community uh
they get a little bit cautious you know
they're BS detector starts to uh to go
off a little bit when you start talking
about circadian biology or Chrono
nutrition anything within that realm and
I under stand why over the past couple
decades circadian biology Chrono
nutrition all these related kind of sub
fields or sub topics they have been
areas where a lot of people who are kind
of the biohacker types have really
focused on these areas with extremely
speculative recommendations and so it's
kind of become a an area where people
kind of expect a high level of BS but
nonetheless this sleep hygiene stuff the
stuff with like dark Cycles circadian
biology this is legit science
um you know when I was in grad school I
took the one of the most it was a
physiology course that there was a
reputation people were scared to death
of this course it was rigorous it was
brutal it was really in depth and we
covered a lot of circadian biology
within that physiology course this is
solid science and I know that some
people have in the past tried to twist
it a little bit or embellish it or you
know really speculate with these
ultra-specific protocols I understand
that people's BS detector goes off when
we get into this realm uh but that
doesn't detract from the from the
legitimacy and the robustness of the
science and this is really legit science
um now when you talk about light dark
cycles and sleep cycles uh I I do have
to mention that there is a a really good
source of information for this stuff so
Andrew huberman has a podcast called the
huberman lab and it's it's funny because
I know a lot of folks in evidence-based
Fitness have have sent me clips from
from the podcast and said
how do you feel about this training
recommendation I said well I disagree
with that I don't think that's really
compatible with the best available
evidence or you know people have brought
me some clips about training about
nutrition about caffeine about
supplementation and there are a great
many topics and a great many
recommendations that I disagree with
when it comes to exercise nutrition
caffeine supplements but
I think that Andrew huberman's work in
his podcast when it comes down to light
dark Cycles sleep regulations circadian
biology I think it's really top-notch
stuff and it makes sense so to my
understanding uh he works and does
research in the fields of neurobiology
and Ophthalmology a kind of the
convergence of uh you know the
neurobiological responses to the eye
perceiving stimuli such as light so for
that reason you know uh I I appreciate
the work he's doing in terms of doing
science communication and getting people
excited about science I don't agree with
all of his recommendations pertaining to
you know the stuff I mentioned
previously in cold exposure and things
like that but that's okay you know you
you can disagree with with you know a
handful of someone's perspectives and
still say and still say hey but I
appreciate the fact that you're doing
science communication you're getting
folks excited about science you're
getting folks excited about physiology
specifically and like I said I think the
work he's doing specifically as it
pertains to light dark Cycles circadian
biology and sleep regulation is really
really excellent stuff
um so yeah I mean and I can empathize
you know like as someone who makes
content there are some areas where I say
oh man we are right in my sweet spot uh
and there are some some times where I'm
kind of drawn out of my wheelhouse or
drawn out of my sweet spot and I cover
areas that are are
um you know less compatible with these
specific research that I've done and and
you know when you start feeling yourself
getting out
um you know getting out on a limb in
some of these less familiar areas uh you
know I can definitely empathize with
with the idea of trying to cover as many
topics as possible but understanding
that some of these topics are are not
squarely within your wheelhouse and
squarely within your very very specific
area of expertise you know when you do a
PhD
or you know graduate Level Training
a lot of times the way people put it is
that you're trying to learn everything
in the world about one little tiny thing
uh so so there's this uh you know really
intense focus on a very particular set
of topics
um so yeah basically what I'm saying is
for more information about sleep light
dark Cycles circadian biology I do think
Andrew huberman's content is very very
good within that realm but since I work
in exercise and nutrition and
supplements I have to put the caveat
that I I'd say well if you want exercise
nutrition stuff
I think it was Stronger by sides folks
do a pretty good job with it but that
that's just my two cents uh so I would
use each resource accordingly in my
opinion uh now some other notable stuff
to to highlight like I said avoiding
caffeine late in the afternoon and
evening when it comes to these really
notable sleep hygiene tips that is one
that is very very high on my list uh a
dark and cool sleep environment that is
also quiet very very critical for
supporting good sleep as I mentioned
earlier letting the mind really relax
before bed finding a way to calm the
mind without doing a lot of really
cognitively demanding or emotionally
demanding stuff before bed uh
and here's an extra tip uh from zen
master tiknot Han who is one of my
favorite people
um I was reading a a very very short
book of his called how to relax and it
has a really interesting recommendation
that has actually been really helpful to
me uh you know sometimes I've been in a
situation where I'm sleeping I wake up
in the middle of the night and I'm just
staring at the ceiling and I'm kind of
annoyed that I can't get back to sleep
and being annoyed is not really
conducive to getting back to sleep
um and so it's a really tough situation
where you're kind of frustrated and
annoyed and agitated that you're not
sleeping but that's not actually helping
you get back to sleep and so in this
book how to relax by technot Han uh he
talks about embracing rest for its own
sake even if you're not falling asleep
so after reading that I've tried it a
few times you know there have been times
where I wake up maybe three or four
hours before I intend to wake up and in
the past I might have been stressed
about it agitated annoyed whatever and I
would have tried very hard to get back
to sleep which is a you know it's easier
said than done now after reading that
recommendation I've had opportunities
where when I wake up in the middle of
the night three or four hours before I
intended I don't stress over being awake
I I just Embrace uh the idea of resting
you know and and you can rest without
sleeping
and so I tried it out and I said you
know what I'm going to give this a shot
I'm just going to say you know what
maybe I won't fall back asleep maybe I
will sit here and calmly and peacefully
enjoy rest you know in an awakened State
awakened uh definitely a hat tip to the
fact that this was a book about Buddhism
but uh but anyway I said I'm just going
to enjoy uh resting for its own sake in
the absence of sleep and what do you
know I I fall asleep very very quickly
when I manage to do that so I would
encourage folks to give that a shot to
consider it you might find that it that
it uh is a tip that is also helpful for
you as it has been for me uh then then
another tip here is
kind of the opposite but but you know if
you're really really struggling to sleep
and you can't even find it you find the
ability to rest you know you're staring
at the ceiling you've tried to calm your
mind and say hey let's just enjoy the
rest here and you realize no
I'm fully awake like there's no chance
that I'm gonna be able to get to sleep
there's no chance that I'm going to be
able to calmly enjoy this rest I am
fully awake and frankly I got stuff to
do
um I'm kind of already prepared to begin
my day now if that's the case just get
out of bed do something else uh don't
get in the habit of restlessly staring
at the ceiling or scrolling through your
phone as you lay in bed and just hoping
something good is going to happen I
would say if you wake up in the middle
of the night I view it as I've got two
options here one is
invest in enjoying this dedicate my mind
to enjoying rest whether or not I fall
back asleep that's one option the other
option is if I just feel ready to go and
I feel well rested and I just want to
start my day get the hell out of bed
just go do stuff um but but that middle
ground of kind of laying there staring
at the ceiling and being annoyed that
you're not sleeping yet uh I really
don't think that's a good strategy
uh all right uh and then just one other
thing I want to reiterate don't do super
intense exercise very very shortly
before bed and once again try to be
mindful of the composition of any food
that you're going to be consuming within
a couple hours of bedtime now the last
topic I want to discuss here is
supplements and I didn't even mention
this when I talked about those tears I
talked about or those categories I said
you know these are my least favorable
strategies for Sleep these are slightly
more favorable these other ones are most
favorable I didn't include supplements
there because I consider supplements to
be just kind of a different thing
altogether it's kind of on a whole
different plane of existence now sleep
hygiene is going to be way more
effective than any supplement you're
trying to take for sleep but some
supplements are still quite helpful so
that's why I want to treat it as a
completely separate thing supplement
moments are not going to be a
replacement for Sleep hygiene and if you
have really really good sleep hygiene
you might find yourself in a situation
where your sleep hygiene is so great
that you don't even need these other
supplements they don't even really do
much beyond the fact that you have a
really excellent sleep wake cycle but if
you want to go the supplement route
there are some supplements that can be
quite helpful in certain scenarios and
this is not an exhaustive list but these
are going to be some of my favorite
supplements that I might lean on if I'm
trying to enhance my sleep quality and
of course as always before you try any
new supplements before you mess around
with any diet or exercise changes check
with a qualified medical professional
just to make sure it's the right thing
for you but a few of my favorites number
one
would be low-dose melatonin uh I usually
don't like to go higher than one
milligram if you look at the research on
melatonin there's some studies showing
efficacy with uh 0.1 or 0.3 milligrams
when you look at the store you see these
enormous doses where people are selling
three five even 10 milligram capsules of
melatonin I like to go very low I like
to go no higher than one milligram the
reason I say one milligram is uh that's
usually about as low as I can find at a
lot of different stores so I actually
take a melatonin product that's designed
for children because I just wanted to
look for the lowest dose I could get my
hands on at the store I am a very
average uh suburban American which means
I do some shopping at Costco which is a
big wholesale Center uh and I was at
Costco and I said what's the lowest
melatonin dose I can get here ended up
being one milligram uh Costco not a
sponsor of the show but they should be
if you know someone at Costco have them
Reach Out uh so low dose melatonin the
reason I like to go low with the dose is
there well there's two reasons first of
all
that's all you need you really don't
need these really high doses of
melatonin uh if you want to facilitate
the onset of sleep uh you know half a
mil half a milligram one milligram
usually that's plenty number two if you
take these really high doses of
melatonin it takes some time for them to
actually kind of clear their way out of
your system what we normally want is you
know like I said these are there are
hormones that experience uh these kind
of circadian linked rhythms we want them
to have Ebbs and flows throughout the
day you know we want melatonin to be
increasing as we are about to go to bed
we want melatonin to be high at the
onset of sleep but we don't want to be
high in perpetuity we don't want to be
high three hours after we wake up the
next morning if we take these huge doses
of melatonin sometimes we see an
abnormally High melatonin level you know
throughout the early portion of the next
day and so yeah we got to sleep but the
next day we feel really sluggish we
don't really feel feel well rested
because we've got this really weird
elevation of melatonin that that would
be atypical if we were not supplementing
with it another one is theonine and
theodine is interesting uh you usually
take you know 100 200 milligrams if I'm
going to take it uh theanine is
interesting because it doesn't
necessarily have a direct sedative
effect but it has a very calming effect
and so a lot of folks notice that
theanine helps them kind of ease into
sleep
um just by by virtue of helping them
kind of reach a a very calm and restful
State another one that I like is
magnesium glycinate and what's really
cool about magnesium glycinate
is that it has magnesium and it has
Glycine and both of these have been
independently shown in some
circumstances to help with sleep in
terms of Sleep Quality and quantity so
the cool thing about magnesium glycinate
is it is a nice form of magnesium but it
also is bringing some glycine to the
table which can be favorable for Sleep
uh the last one I want to mention here
is tart cherry extract and this one is
interesting because I don't see much of
it on the market when it comes to sleep
supplements for whatever reason it's
been mentioned many times in the
literature especially in the last couple
years but formulators don't really seem
to be coming around and really utilizing
it too much in sleep formulas not really
sure why I do expect they'll catch on
eventually but there's something in tart
cherry extract called Pro cyanidin B2
and what it does is it enhances
tryptophan bio availability and that's
gonna it if you enhance the
bioavailability of tryptophan that can
facilitate the endogenous production of
melatonin and serotonin so melatonin and
serotonin these are both hormones that
we expect to have some Ebbs and flows
some ups and downs Peaks and valleys
however you want to put it that help us
regulate our our kind of pattern
throughout the night as we're falling
asleep as we're sleeping and then as
we're ultimately waking up you don't
really want to massively disrupt these
normal fluctuations and melatonin and
serotonin but you do want to make sure
that the raw materials are there to
facilitate their endogenous production
so I'm not you know there is some
research that just supplementing with
tryptophan can be uh helpful for
sleep-related outcomes but I actually
prefer
to have a bit of a softer touch uh a
less aggressive approach where instead
of just adding a bunch of tryptophan to
the situation I like to uh lean on tart
cherry extract in the hopes that I will
simply enhance the bioavailability of
the tryptophan that's already present uh
little conflict of interest disclosure I
just mentioned uh my favorite sleep
related supplements
um and so of course or my favorite sleep
related supplement ingredients I do have
to disclose and want to disclose that I
helped a company formulate a sleep
product with these ingredients it's not
available yet when it becomes available
I'll probably talk about it a little bit
more so obviously that product reflects
my preferred ingredients because I you
know gave a lot of advice about how that
product ought to look so it's not that I
am retrofitting my favorite ingredients
to match the that supplement it's that
the supplement looks that way because
you know this is how I see the
literature pertaining to sleep related
supplement ingredients so there's a
company called uh Joy mode that makes
some supplements uh pertaining they they
have a couple different supplements uh
and and one that should be coming in the
near future is going to be one that is
intended to support high quality sleep
so
I just wanted to disclose that conflict
of interest so that nobody would you
know say hey wait a minute it looks like
you're just pushing some product you
know whenever that hits the market
um but but I like I said uh if I was
talking to someone and they were saying
hey I'm sleeping like crap what should I
do I would probably talk about eight or
nine different sleep hygiene tips before
we even got into the conversation about
uh dietary supplements but if you were
looking at some supplement ingredients
uh those are the ones that that I would
probably
um consider and once again after
Consulting with a qualified medical
professional all right so I want to wrap
up this episode with a quick summary
insufficient sleep can impede progress
toward a number of Fitness related goals
more specifically it can negatively
impact performance appetite body
composition and Recovery
insufficient sleep can be temporarily
mitigated by caffeine and napping and
you can also modify your training
program to try to salvage a good workout
while you're currently under slept or
you have a great deal of sleep debt in
addition there are some dietary
supplements that can favorably impact
sleep but nonetheless the best thing you
can do is focus on maintaining really
really good sleep hygiene in order to
improve the quantity and the quality of
your sleep if sleep is getting between
you and your fitness goals you want to
get right to the source and try to make
your sleep better and sleep hygiene
principles are the most straightforward
way to do that
now before I end this episode I hope
you'll once again afford me the
opportunity
to make a very Shameless sales pitch on
behalf of macro factor that is the diet
app that Greg and I co-developed along
with a very talented team of colleagues
uh so imagine you're having some sleep
disturbances you might be thinking am I
having too much caffeine am I consuming
caffeine too late in the day am I eating
too close to bedtime my pre-bed meal is
it too large is it too fatty is it too
spicy am I having too much alcohol
before bed as we've talked about these
are all things to consider if you're
experiencing sleep disturbances well
that's easy just check macro Factor okay
so macro factor is a very efficient food
logger with a robust verified food
database but it logs your food on an
actual hour by hour timeline so rather
than just putting your meals into the
breakfast bucket or the lunch bucket or
The Dinner Bucket you actually have a
timeline where you are logging not just
what you ate and how much but you are
logging when you ate it so that enables
some of these time related nutrition
insights and this is just one
application of where that could come in
handy so as you consider the wide
variety of diet approaches and dietary
strategies that you might Implement in
the New Year rest assured macro factor
is going to be able to facilitate most
likely whatever you're planning to do
it's very efficient it's a very flexible
the coaching programs or the coached
macro programs I should say are
extremely flexible but you can even use
a collaborative program or a manual
program to crank up the flexibility even
higher whatever your food Choice
preferences are whatever your macro
preferences are macro Factor can handle
it so to learn more
check out macrofactorapp.com or you can
just search for it in the app stores
as always thank you for joining me for
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast you might have noticed
we've been doing a lot of episodes we
pushed right through uh November
December clear into January we blew
right through the typical winter holiday
break that we normally take so we're
going to be taking a little break here
so the next few weeks we're not going to
have any episodes I need to rest and
recover and try to resolve some of this
uh stuff that's going on with the Union
they're totally illegal totally
incorrect strike that they're doing so
keep an eye on our social media channels
uh the stronger by science social media
channels for more information about when
our next season is going to begin until
then take care and good luck with all of
your fitness goals
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter or just
go to the stronger by science homepage
and click the free programs button at
the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
thank you